hey youtubers is Charlie so there's a
whole bunch of flash season 2 stuff
happening right now the biggest question
that we still have an answer though is
who is the blue flash in that promo if
you never read the comics and you didn't
watch the classic TV show they're just
their number of versions of the flash
that have worn blue costumes before like
if you go back to the John Wesley Shipp
flash show the classic flash 90s series
there was a cloned version of the
character that wore a blue costume if
you go back in the comics he was a blue
lantern during the war of light so then
he had a blue costume but he was wearing
a blue Lantern ring so that was why the
costume was blue and then more recently
in the new 52 before futures end we saw
a future version of Barry Allen that
wore a blue costume some of you've been
asking me questions about cobalt blue
who's a different character his name is
Malcolm Thawne he looks like what Eddie
used to look like on the TV show he was
like a long-lost brother of Barry Allen
that was raised by thawne's so he had
Allen DNA but a Thawne name that's why
you know a lot of people thought that
Eddie might be cobalt blue during season
1 turns out that's not the case but he's
not really part of my consideration for
season 2 of the flash the actor that
plays Eddie Ric cos net was just cast is
a main character on another TV show so
don't expect him to show up for an
extended period of time on flash season
2 anybody that's going to be the main
villain of flash season 2 is gonna have
to be in the majority of episodes so
it's not going to be some guest star
that's going to show up at the last
minute and then take off right away
it'll be more like season 1 where we're
not sure who the character is but they
show up all the time without without us
really realizing it Tom Cavanagh said
after season what part of what drew him
to the show is is the idea of playing
dual roles it's kind of like Tatiana
maslany on orphan black you know one
person playing multiple characters he
said that that's going to continue in
season two he didn't say how like he
didn't say he's going to be the villain
but because we know we're going to get
earth to and because this character here
this you know blue flash running around
is supposed to be zoom I think the show
might be taking dual identities to the
next level I mean that's what earth two
is all about about like you know what
would the world look like if everybody
made different choices the only
characters right now that we know for
sure that are coming from Earth 2 are
Jay Garrick who we hear in the trailer
you know you're
world is in danger in zoom the danger
that he's talking about is zoom so in
addition to new speedsters we're
probably going to see alternate versions
of characters that already exists on the
show I know a lot of people are
wondering how caitlin snow is supposed
to become killer frost like will killer
frost be the earth-2 version of caitlyn
or will it be our caitlin that's not
really important for what i'm talking
about right now this video is mostly
about the blue flashes from the comics
and zoom from the TV show it can be a
little confusing because zoom in the
comics is like a number of different
things like you know the comics change
things all the time typically when
people talk about zoom they're talking
about hunter zolomon
that was the geoff johns era zoom he was
the one that took the mantle of the
reverse-flash from professor zoom a Bart
dawn now everybody got a little bit
confused when I talked about professor
zoom and a Bart thought in my last flash
video so in the comics a bar Don's name
is Professor zoom the reverse flash is
like the blanket name that you give to
whoever like you know that the Flash's
greatest enemy is at any given time so
professor zoom and zoom two completely
different characters in the comics the
show did a bard Thawne but I don't think
that they ever directly called him
professor zoom I think the show only
ever referred to him as the reverse
flash so I'll try to be clear whenever
I'm using different names for the
different reverse flashes thankfully the
TV show simplifies a lot of things don't
worry like that they will fully explain
it so if you don't want to read the
comics you won't have to you'll still
totally be able to follow it this
character right here is going to be zoom
but I think they took a lot of
inspiration from a couple different
things in the comics and I want to give
you a few more ideas when your theory
crafting about who zoom might be so
right now like the footage that they use
to make this promo it's actually old
footage from the flash season 1 they
just they changed the colors so it
looked like it was new footage so the
flash is yellow looking lightning looks
blue now in his costume looks a little
black I think there's a little bit of
eye winking to the John Wesley Shipp era
with with the Pollux character with like
that you know the blue flash costume the
alternate version like the evil clone
and the future flash from the new 52
comics so I'm going to have to explain
who the future blue flash is from the
new 52 era so careful
for spoilers from that because it's
really critical to understanding some of
the themes that they're working with in
the flash season 2 so the future flash
of the new 52 universe is Barry Allen
from 20 years in the future his
storyline is the culmination of like a
lifetime of Barry being late to things
not being able to save people so 20
years in the future he comes to the
conclusion like he finds a way to fix
everything so he starts jumping around
in time it starts causing fractures in
the Speed Force and creating really
really big problems in the past his
solution at a certain point is to go
back in time and sacrifice himself so
you get to this really awesome future
Barry versus past Barry panel
thematically it was very similar to
Barry Allen's arc on the TV show in
season one you know he was trying to go
back in time and save his mother in the
case of the comics like blue flash blue
future flash was trying to go back in
time and save Wally West
so I mean it all works out this is like
right before convergence so they've
completely wiped this and the new Barry
out like the new post convergence Barry
Allen looks like this so like his
costume has changed again but as crazy
as all that sounds just think about it
this way like Barry Allen wants to go
back and change things he's like I think
I think I can go back and save my mother
I think he even said that in that promo
like he starts second-guessing himself
so he starts to go really dark he gets
more violent than 20 years in the future
at the end of his rope he suddenly
realizes like I know how to fix this all
they're not gonna do that on the TV show
it's it's not going to be that dark but
what if Earth twos version of Barry is
the Xoom character like what if Barry is
the villain of season 2 that might not
be where the TV show is going like they
might not do it that way but I really
like them taking the idea of dual
identities and earth 1 and earth 2 to
like the next level in season 2 Caitlin
snow is the best example of that
character - we have our version of
Caitlin then we have the alternate
future killer frost version what is this
internal battle that's going to be going
on with Caitlin snow that's going to
drive her over the edge
maybe that has something to do with
what's going on between Barry and his
battle with zoom in season 2 typically
what happens is is the theme of each
season spills across all the characters
arcs so here's my big question for you
guys do you think the TV show would ever
go to that place where they let Grant
Gustin be
villain or do you think they're going to
do something more traditional where zoom
is going to be like an alternate version
of the reverse-flash
just remember that like any theory that
you come up with
however elaborate is probably going to
be more spectacular than what the
reality of the show is going to be
typically shows are made so the people
that don't read comics can follow them
so I'm expecting zoom on the TV show to
be way less complex so it probably is
going to be a different character it
probably won't be like an evil version
of Barry but if you want to read that
comic book storyline where like evil
Barry from the future comes back and
tries to kill Pass Barry well
technically he's not evil he's just
super dark but it's all about the
creation of Wally West that that's
really like the end goal of the
storyline it starts in the new 52 run
with flash number 30 I actually feel
like that's a pretty important run to
read because it introduces a bi-racial
Wally West they said Wally West is going
to be african-american on the TV show no
idea how the story is going to surface
them he could come from Earth too he
could get his power some other way it
won't be exactly like it happened in the
comics like like nothing they do on the
TV show is exactly like they do it on
the comics usually when they do a
storyline from the comics they just use
a lot of visual references so hopefully
you guys are like a little bit closer to
figuring out who zoom is on the TV show
I would advise you to develop at least
like two or three different theories
because the show could take any number
of directions and we will be seeing both
versions of the reverse-flash again from
season one the yellow costume
reverse-flash will be seeing both Matt
Ledger who played the first version of
eobard thawne before he sucked in the
DNA of Harrison wells and it became like
the Tom Cavanagh reverse-flash will be
seeing a Bart Thawne and Harrison wells
both in season two but in different
contexts than they were in season one
they won't be doing the exact same
things and in their characters will be
just a little bit different but let me
know what all your theories are like why
is zoom going to jump to earth 1 and
what is it he's going to try to do the
team flash is going to have to stop and
do you think that he's going to try and
co-op some of our characters like will
he be responsible for Caitlin snow
becoming killer frost that might explain
what's going on with firestorm in season
2 as well but like will will actually
see firestorm in the first episode so
we'll know what's going on with him
right away
so in a couple weeks they're actually
going to be doing a big press conference
we'll talk about the flash season two we
might even get an official trailer with
like brand-new footage they've been
shooting for a while so they definitely
got it Stephen Amell has also been
posting a lot of pictures from the arrow
set along with the other characters he's
been posting a lot of like really
sleeveless new Green Arrow costume
pictures so whenever the flash does
their press conference will also
probably find out a bunch of arrow stuff
- it's like a combined CW press
conference so I'll be doing videos for
all that stuff whenever it happens be
sure to subscribe to get everything and
if you guys didn't know I'm actually
doing a weekly DC giveaway it's just it
the schedules been a little crazy
because of Comic Con and stuff all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'm going to be posting another
arrow season 4 video and like a day or
two so I'll just announce the winner
whenever I post that really big news -
they actually yesterday they published
this new reverse flash comic that's
actually this really cool story about
post convergence and what's going on
with the characters they changed the way
the Speed Force works so if you guys
want me to do a video about that I'll
make a flash video about that next week
so well you guys wait for all that stuff
you can click here to learn all about
killer frost in the comics learn about
her comic book history and you can click
here to learn all about Game of Thrones
plan for eight seasons they just confirm
eight seasons and a prequel show so
everybody flip out it's going to be
amazing
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow